herzlich willkommen zur verließ welt
heute gibt es wieder eine motiv torte
von mir und zwar haben sich ganz viele
meiner zuschauer eine einschulung torte
gewünscht und ich habe bereits vor zwei
jahren schon mal eine einstellungsquote
gemacht damals in form einer schultüte
und halte ich mir gedacht mach ich mal
was anderes wieder eine 3d torte und
habe einen schulranzen gebacken und
dekoriert und zwar ist es ein scout
schulranzen den hatte ich früher als
kind auch den hatte jeder der sich jeder
gut ich hatte ihn von new york
du hast doch keinen bekommt nächstes als
ich und meine ruhe daten müssen ja also
die sanierer kommen längst in die schule
jetzt ist noch kein schulanfänger und
damals zum trotz haben die grenzen eben
noch so aus also einfach ein viereckiger
kasten aber auf jeden fall richtig cool
und ja in dem kuchen steckt er unter
dieser fondant decke steckt ein schoko
und vanille kuchen und java sagt am ende
des friedens gibt es übrigens eine
kleine überraschung erzähle geschichten
wirklich geschichte achtung ich als ich
eingeschult wurde ich habe einen kleinen
bruder da ist dreieinhalb jahre jünger
als ich und gerade in dem jahr also ich
war noch ein jahr zusammen im
kindergarten und dann musste ich in die
schule oder durften in die schule und
meine eltern gesagt ich darf mir ein
schulranzen eben aussuchen und hab mir
damals in aller erster schulranzen war
so ein lila schulranzen mit einhörnern
drauf und das problem dabei war mein
papa hat er war als sparsam und wollte
das eben mein bruder daneben auch den
schulranzen nimmt und dann musste mein
bruder der arm mit dreieinhalb jahre
später mit dem einhorn schulranzen
rumlaufen und deswegen war mein zweiter
schulranzen in der dritten klasse den
ich dann bekommen habe ja da habe ich
mir halt einen grauen aussuchen müssen
ich stand da elisabeth nicht aus muss
seinen grauen ja also ich stand da in
dem laden müsst euch mal vor schon so
viele tolle schulranzen und mein papa
sagt nee nee der graue wird uns
jetzt doch lieber gerne pink oder keine
ahnung was mir gefallen hat jedenfalls
musste ich mir dann den grauen aussuchen
und dann durfte mein bruder den
dreieinhalb jahre später eben auch
nehmen und hat den schulranzen gab es
bis vor kurzem sogar einen monat vor
einem monat mein papa hat nämlich als
genau den schulranzen vom papa werkzeug
dritten rang zwei dahinter im kofferraum
da hatten wir ein werkzeug kann nach wie
vielen im ort geschenkt bekommen und
jetzt ist der schwarze weg eigentlich
glaube ich dass mein bruder meine
schwester daran schuld sind die haben
eben einen werkzeugkasten geschenkt
jetzt ist mein aber woran sind von
damals leiter nicht mehr da naja
deswegen habe ich mir jetzt einen
gebacken und ich finde es jetzt eine
ganz coole idee ist es auch nicht ganz
schwierig also im inneren steckt ja
wirklich ein ganz toller kuchen und er
wird einfach nur quadratisch
zugeschnitten und gestapelt und dann
dekoriert aber wir starten jetzt direkt
wird schon zu legen
ok also mit legos für die tochter wird
schon ein bisschen aus vorbereitet und
zwar habe ich hier einmal einen
schokokuchen den saftigen und den habe
ich auch noch mal ein hell gebacken das
heißt ich habe statt derzeit
bitterschokolade eine weiße schokolade
genommen und einfach cacau weggelassen
und mehl genommen die böden habe ich
jetzt bereits geld fand schon gebacken
und habe auch schon eine portion star
peter karrasch hergestellt
muss ich die böden erstmal aus der form
lösen und die habe ich jetzt in einer
größe 25 mal 30 gebacken und einfach so
ein bisschen größer gemacht weil ich mir
gestern noch nicht ganz sicher war
welche größe die der schulranzen haben
wird
als nächstes werde ich jetzt die
tortenböden erst einmal waagerecht
schneiden damit sie die gleiche höhe
haben denn später beim anschnitt wird
die torte schwarz weiß sein und das
jetzt eben gut aus wenn sie alle die
gleiche höhe haben das mache ich jetzt
mit einer torten sich aber wir können
natürlich auch ein ganz normales messer
benutzen
da nehme ich jetzt die kuren reste weg
die brauche ich jetzt erstmal nicht mehr
und die könnt ihr zum beispiel benutzen
und cake pops zu machen oder ein anderes
bisher
als nächstes muss sich detail jetzt
zurechtschneiden der schulranzen wird er
aufgestellt sein und deswegen habe ich
jetzt hier schon mal eine tortenplatte
zurechtgeschnitten
die hat jetzt die größe 20 x 8 cm und
die torte wird also man sich auf 20 cm
auch hoch sein dann und jetzt schneiden
sie einfach die teigplatten zu rechnen
kann sie dann auch gleich staffeln
habe ich die zeit bilden
zurechtgeschnitten und jetzt nehme ich
hier diese cache platte die tortenplatte
und bestreikt sie etwas mit der kanal
damit die torte eben auch drauf haften
bleibt jetzt kommt der erste boden trat
dann nehme ich jetzt mal den schoko
boden und jetzt wird die torte mittag
als auch gefüllt und dann immer im
wechsel schwarz und weiß geschichtet und
zwar so lange bis ihr die perfekte höhe
habt
die torte muss jetzt erst mal in den
kühlschrank für etwa eine halbe stunde
dann wird die gans fest und dann kann
ich sie von außen mit der garage
komplett bestreiten
schön glatt streichen und dann wird er
schon dekoriert während die torte kühl
steht kann ich jetzt schon mal ein
bisschen weiter arbeiten und zwar bitte
hier bei dem scout schulranzen vorne
dieses mädchen dran und das mache ich
jetzt auch aus den kuchen resten und
kann es dann auch kühl stellen und nehme
jetzt hier einfach mal den teil und zwar
ist die torte jetzt insgesamt 20
zentimeter breit und wird etwa 20
zentimeter hoch und deswegen schneide
ich zu den teil 17 zentimeter breit und
15 meter hoch
und da mach ich sieht so dass ich jetzt
zwei schichten machen damit einfach ein
bisschen dicker aussieht dass das
mädchen noch gefüllt aussieht und
schneidet dann vorne aber so ein
bisschen rundlich zurecht
und den teil kann ich jetzt auch schon
mal mit der nacht bestreichen und dann
einfach kühl stellen
befeuchtet jetzt mit der garage straße
werde ich jetzt noch einmal zu schneiden
dass sie wirklich rechts und links den
gleichen geraden abschluss hat
jetzt wird die torte mit der ganache
gestrichen das mache ich in zwei
schichten immer die erste schicht die
krümelig dass die krümel gebunden werden
anschließend wir die torte für 15
minuten kalt gestellt und dann wird
abgestrichen
die zwischenzeiten sich jetzt immer
wieder und wieder mal die deko herstellt
und zwar hat einen schulranzen ja oben
auch diesen henkel dann nämlich grüne
modelle schokolade der jetzt bereits
weiß geknetet und rollen sie auch ein
bisschen becker stärke auf 1 zentimeter
stärke aus
jetzt schneide ich daraus auch einen 1
cm breiten streifen
seit ich vorne und hinten das schön
gerade weg und kann dann den hebel hier
auf dieses 20 cm stück daten legen dann
weiß ich nämlich wie die proportion sein
muss
jetzt kommt da noch fürs gelenk weil
eigentlich ist der hebel beweglich kommt
einfach noch ein kleiner schlitz rein
und man kann da jetzt erst mal zur seite
und ich mache aus dem gleichen grün
das habe ich jetzt noch mal 3 mm dünner
ausgerollt mache ich jetzt noch die
schnallen für vorne drauf und die mache
ich jetzt 3 cm breit und etwa 4 cm lang
nach unten hin werde jetzt ein bisschen
schmaler deswegen nehme ich da rechts
und links noch was weg
muss ich dir einmal halbieren und muss
das gleiche dann nochmal herstellen
hab ich hier noch etwas roten von dort
ganz dünn ausgerollt und so werden diese
reflektoren auf der schnalle
damit dies etwas strukturiert bekomme
nehme ich hier so legt es darauf und
streich einfach ein bisschen drüber
die reflektoren haben wir so ein
bisschen struktur
kann man es hier auch ganz leicht sehen
jetzt muss ich den der größe zuschneiden
und dann einfach am rand etwa 2 bis 3 mm
klein schneiden
ich habe jetzt etwas roten und gelben
von dort gemischt und zwar habe ich
jetzt 750 gramm rot und etwa 200 gramm
geld genommen damit ich einfach so ein
dunkleres orange bekomme und jetzt werde
ich die torte damit überziehen aber erst
einmal die seitenteile und dann den rest
erst vier die seitenteile die muss ich
jetzt natürlich zuerst aus schnaitsee
zurecht und klebt dann dran beim
zuschneiden können jetzt darauf achten
dass ihr ein bisschen puffer rechts und
links und oben und unten habt dann könnt
ihr das nämlich im anschluss einfach
wegschneiden
die torte fertig jetzt mit etwas back
transport damit davon dann auch gut
drauf haftet
und jetzt nehmt ihr einfach zwei fordert
wirken können dann die seiten aus
glätten
mit dem tier einen scharfen kater und
könnte jetzt die ränder noch
wegschneiden
ich nicht
für die äußere hülle brauche ich jetzt
ein langes band was so breit wie die
torte ist und ebenso lang wie der
komplette überzog
also man muss jetzt einmal diese
komplette fläche rechnen das sind jetzt
etwa 20 zentimeter das x 2 und das oben
schon bisher mathematik abgeschafft
bestimmtes zusammenzurechnen
und bei mir sind es 46 zentimeter und
dann rechnen sie einfach ein bisschen
puffer noch mit 1
und das soll ich jetzt auf den ausbau
starb auf wohl die torte und kann es
dann ganz einfach drüber ausrollen
jetzt einfach alle seiten wieder glätten
und dann die überreste wegschneiden
für den deckel habe ich jetzt hier
bereits ein quadrat zurechtgeschnitten
wobei sich nicht ganzen quadrat denn die
breite sind 21 5 und die länger sind 220
cm und damit ich jetzt den deckel gut
auf die auf den schulranzen bekomme
nehme ich jetzt in wachs papier
ihr könnt aber auch im wald papier zum
beispiel nehmen und das wachstum hier
bestreite ich jetzt mit etwas kostet
dann sagt nämlich davon dort gleich
darauf haften
und dann habe ich eben einfacher die
platte jetzt darüber zu bekommen denn
ansonsten wird sie sich jetzt ein
bisschen zu ziehen
die platte versieht sich also maximal
vier einstreichen
damit drauf legen jetzt haft ist
instagram muss ich es einmal wenn
unternehme ich jetzt so einem teig
retter oder ihr können doch was anderes
flaches benutzen
mit kanada erst mal weg jetzt streiche
ich etwas essbaren kleber auf die platte
denn verstrahlte ich jetzt mit einem
pinsel
und damit ich es jetzt ganz gerade
ansätze markiere ich mir hier am besten
eine linie
jetzt könnt ihr das lineal oder einen
anderen gegenstand zu hilfe nehmen und
es einfach noch ein bisschen gerade
schieben nämlich hier ein werkzeug und
zwar kann ich damit jetzt die nähte noch
ein bisschen andeuten und das mache ich
es einfach rundherum
die torte steht jetzt kurz im
kühlschrank
jetzt kann ich dieses kleine mädchen da
vorne also dem bauch des schulranzens
noch überziehen
da bleibe jetzt ein bisschen gelb
genommen und habe auch diese kleine
torte mit etwas wagt renz brill
eingefettet
die
jetzt kommt hier noch die reißverschluss
abdeckung drauf und die klebe ich dann
auch wieder mit essbarem kleber dran
jetzt wird sich noch eine tortenplatte
mit vom land und zu habe ich jetzt hier
500 gramm vanille und 250 gramm schoko
und das werdet ein bisschen marmoriert
und ausgerollt und dann kann ich die
platte damit überziehen
jetzt kann man diese monierte platte so
lassen oder könnte noch strukturieren
zum beispiel mit seinem struktur roller
oder aber auch einfach mit eurem
werkzeug jetzt einfach wieder auf den
aus hall starb aufrollen und die platte
mit essbarem kleber bestreiten und dann
drüber rollen unter stimmung hat
ausschau
für die tasche stelle ich jetzt noch
einen super her also den reißverschluss
vorne aber da brauchen wir jetzt nur den
verschluss da habe ich jetzt schwarzen
modelle schokolade und ich nehme da auch
herr modelle schokolade weil die eben
gut aushärtet nämlich da einfach ein
kleines stückchen und formen des mit der
hand und zwar erst mal flach drücken
dieses kleine stück halte ich jetzt
das bleibt erst mal so da kommt da noch
mal ein längliches stück das ich jetzt
unten loch jetzt muss sie noch hier
vorne in so eine kleine vertiefung
einschneiden für eine kleine öffnung
jetzt werden die teile noch
zusammengeklebt
jetzt kommt auch noch ein bisschen der
metallic effekt drauf mit etwas
silbernem farbpulver und das kann ich
ganz trocken einfach drauf pinseln
ich habe etwas gar nach wird die torte
jetzt mit ich auf das skateboard setzen
das ist gut
es soll ja holz sein
und jetzt sitzt die torte auf der platte
und ich kann jetzt auch die dekoration
und vornehmen und eben auch alles
angegeben
das heißt ich fange jetzt zuerst einmal
auf der rückseite noch an
mit den trägern verbraucher träger
geldermann schulranzen hat sagt man
vorne und hinten natürlich nicht
verwechseln
hier ist hinten jetzt kann ich hier erst
mal auf grüner modelle schokolade die
träger ausschneiden und zwar schlecht
einfach ganz lange bänder und da nehme
ich jetzt auch wieder modelle schokolade
weil die reben festwirt und eben nicht
so ganz weich ist wie fondant
jetzt habe ich hier noch ein gelbes band
und das gebe ich mich an gewalt das
grüne
hier unten ein bisschen kleber wieder
dran streichen
ich lege jetzt die träger hier noch
drauf und lass sie so ein bisschen an
trocken bevor ich sie jetzt komplett an
kleber
es geht dann ein bisschen einfacher und
dafür legte jetzt einfach so ein
bisschen küchenrolle da zwischen den
vorderen teil behielt mit etwas garage
an die torte
ich lebe jetzt zuerst einmal die ganzen
teile drauf die folgen vorbereitet haben
sollen können die träger jetzt einfach
ein bisschen an trockenen und fest
werden
hier will jetzt auch schwarzer
modelliert schokolade so strenge gemacht
die werde ich jetzt wieder silber ein
pinsel oder wie sagt man da für
stockenden weise der richtige ausdruck
von sally und dann wird es hier noch an
die schnelle geklebt
die
hier vier kreise ausgestochen und die
werde ich jetzt noch ein bisschen
zurechtschneiden und es kommt dann auf
die ecken von schulranzen ich gab es
doch früher immer der ecken schutz dass
der schulranzen überlegung schlange hebt
der ecken schutz das war uns vor wie sie
lkw planen ich kann es sein die haben
nur weg gekoppelt dass du irgendwann
keine
jetzt fehlt beim scout schulranzen da
vorne noch das namensschild es kennt ihr
wahrscheinlich also jeder dessen frau
hatte weiß hier an der seite kommt auf
dem namensschild rein und dafür habe ich
jetzt schon weiß und fondant vor ihn
ausgerollt ein bisschen antrocknen
lassen
und wenn es jetzt einfach rechteckig so
schneiden dann nehme ich jetzt ein
aussteiger dafür aber das geht auch ganz
einfach mit dem messer dann noch die
umrandung da hab ich jetzt hier noch die
grüne modell ihr schokolade stetig in
der gleichen größe aus und dann kommt
jetzt der kleine ausschnitte damit man
durchgucken kann jetzt kommen dann auch
linien drauf und dann kann ich mit
lebensmittel farbstiften noch den namen
drauf schreiben
jetzt kann ich den rahmen mit etwas
kleber an papier und dann an den schuhen
kleben
zum stabilisieren der erträge habe ich
jetzt einfach rein gesteckt damit es
einfach ein bisschen an trocknen kann
falls sie aber die zeit habt könnt ihr
natürlich die träger schon zwei drei
tage im voraus vorbereitet und die dann
einfach durch trocknen lassen dann habe
das sehr einfach wenn wir das jetzt sehr
kurzfristig im prinzip habe ich die
torte so wie es eigentlich auf fertig
und dem rad kann sie gleich probieren
also das ist jetzt ungefähr ticket orte
und jetzt anschneiden
aber bevor ich sie am schneide
vielleicht ganz kurz zur überraschung
oder genau das habe ich heute morgen
genau spd erst werde überlegt an wir
machen jetzt getraut haben uns überlegt
wir rufen einfach mal fest kaut an
und der muss dann immer ganz spontan er
hat ganz erklärt ich habe das für ein
englisches unternehmen ist aber gar
nicht erst gar nicht das kommt aus
frankenthal ist unternehmer und ich habe
jetzt einfach kurz anrufen einfach auf
verdacht und habe dann gefragt obwohl
damit der marketingleiterin verbunden
und habt ein bisschen erzählen was sie
machen das tolle sie kennt ist es schon
und ich habe gefragt ob sie unterstützen
können für die zuschauer genau und jetzt
bekommen wir sechs schulranzen mit
kompletten set und der kosten 650 euro
leisten set dabei mit mit 1 24 der
schule züge irgendwie in einen
schlampigen stand beutel nass tasche und
irgendwie glaube meine sachen sport und
mit nacht genau lautet macho seien sie
dabei und das klima dreimal suite cherry
genau und 3 x lion rangers ich denke mal
ein mädchen und die mittels unter euch
verlosen und dafür aber uns ein richtig
cooles gewinnspiel überlegt und zwar
habt ihr also welt diesen dieses
schulzeit gewinnen möchte hat
wahrscheinlich kinder die jetzt gerade
eingeschult werden
und ich denke jeder von euch hat noch
ein einstellungs foto und wir würden es
richtig cool finden wenn ihr uns einfach
ein einstellungs foto von euch schickt
oder zusendet oder unter diesem beitrag
teilt und zwar entweder auf facebook
oder auf instagram mit dem hashtag was
einmal gesagt sallys kompletten den
hashtag 1
und genau
das ist übrigens mein welt da sieht man
ganz toll meinen lieben schulranzen und
dieses schwarze wasserdichte an schwarz
weißes kleid mit dieser strumpfhose und
dem tollen schon genau und mein bruder
der musste immer mit aufs bild also
meiner mama die hat darauf gestand dass
mein kleiner bruder immer mit aufs bild
geht ich war bei ihm mit drauf er war
bei mir mit drauf es gibt keine
hässlichen kinder ausnahmen bestätigen
die regel
ich hoffe dass bald keine anspannung ab
wir wollen ich mal auf der baumschule
ist so wie ich das sehe auf jeden fall
es gibt leider keine bilder von mir oder
hoher ein zaun und es klappt werden kann
aber ich zeig mal ein kinderbild von dir
weil ich finde war schon richtig dieser
kleine junge weiß ja jedenfalls würde
ich mich freuen wenn ihr uns einfach ein
bild von euch einsendet und uns markiert
und dann werden wir unter den
teilnehmern einfach die im schulranzen
verlosen
und als er sich setzte und das ganze
dann schriftlich also wir werden euch
schriftlich super wäre es wirklich wenn
ihr das wirklich nur machen wenn ihr
wenn ihr wirklich kinder habt jetzt
eingeschult werden und die eben noch
keinen schulranzen haben genau
ja klar du willst ja meine alte schule
sowie ein land gerade schreiben
schreiben sie und himmel
lisa und himmel kann schon mal steuer
indikation store schreiben an eine ganz
ganz schnell und zwar ich habe da meine
hunde gefragt ihr kennt doch diese
schultypen
ja und ich musste viel größer und meine
eltern also ich so gemacht die haben
ungefähr drei viertel der schultüte mit
mit papier ausgekleidet und unrecht da
oben das ist ein bisschen voll aus sagt
war die schokolade und ich dachte
wirklich hat jeder gemacht habe ich
meine runde gefragt niemand keiner seine
eltern haben das gemacht zwar nur meine
eltern also ich würd man von euch kann
wissen ob es eure eltern möglich die
schultüte komplett gefüllt oder mit
wasser auf dem feld genau das wird mich
meine eltern nicht der einzige war es
jemals erlebt hat sagte anschneiden
wenn man es anschaut dann sieht es aus
hier wie sowie ein kredit aus marzipan
wenn mir so anschaue marzipan baum
stammt es aus der weiße schokolade und
jetzt nachdem je nachdem um ex freund
mag oder nicht ich weiß es nicht so süß
ist alles heißt ich kann mit ist wir
essen denn von dann immer mit ich mache
nichts zu denken
schule war schreibe ich denn und dem
morath kann erzählen wie er schmeckt
also richtig schön schokolade schmeckt
ganz schön saftig der schmitten nicht
trocken
schmeckt wie eine krähe und echt lecker
das freut mich dass jetzt auch lust
bekommen habt auf diese torte dann geht
auf 6 - dog days stehen natürlich noch
mal die ganzen mengenangaben und da gibt
es auch ein paar schritt für schritt
bilder aus dem video und ich freue mich
wenn ihr bei dem gewinnspiel mitmacht
und freue mich schon auf die ganz vielen
einsendungen eurer fotos wenn ihr könnt
mir auch so dass somal und foto eure
einstellung schicken und vielleicht
einfach dazu schreiben ob ihr einen
schulranzen gewinnen wollt oder nicht
daran ein paar mehr bilder zum anderen
müssten beschreiben jüngere mädchen
stimmt weil wir haben ja wie chery und
lyle ranger vermögen also viel spaß beim
nachmachen und wir sehen uns das nächste
mal ist dann alles möglich schön saftig
süß standort essen und ich liebe es mit
samira noch ein bisschen schule mit
übungs geschrieben sle schule bringen
bitte nichts falsches bald auf den papa
hör auf mich okay ich hab hier darf